Georgia gubernatorial candidate Stacy
Abram says abortion can help address
inflation issues why that's right if
you're concerned about the rising costs
for your household consider killing your
unborn child that's the news apparently
so uh you know she said you can't
divorce being forced to carry an
unwanted pregnancy from the economic
realities of having a child Abrams
continued adding that we don't have the
luxury of reducing it or separating them
out Abrams avoided offering policy
solutions to counter-inflation instead
saying that a governor can address
housing prices a governor can address
the cost of Education blah blah blah
okay so here's the point
we used to have um institutions in this
country to make sure that if women got
pregnant that uh there was a means and
resources made available to her and that
was called marriage that uh we had
shotgun weddings you guys know about
that right dude would get a girl
pregnant the dad would go you're
marrying my daughter and that's a that's
a Trope it's a meme but once they break
down that institution you now have women
who are like Oh no I got pregnant and
the guy has abandoned me okay they're
supposed to be child support laws and
payments for a reason Stacey Abrams
could offer up I don't know that instead
she's like women are concerned about the
cost of goods because they're about to
have a baby has she considered that
perhaps the reason some women might not
want the pregnancy is that they fear not
being able to afford it and so the issue
isn't that they should abort the baby
they may actually really want the kid
that's how insane and nightmarish this
is so how about we abort inflation that
might be a good start if it's a
financial concern yeah we can get rid of
that maybe we can uh deal with
fractional Reserve banking policies
quantitative easing the Federal Reserve
yeah how about you just stop printing
money out of thin air giving it to the
biggest companies on Wall Street how
about you just stop spending money
willy-nilly on stupid projects and then
maybe you know people could afford
having children and you don't have to
abort them which is absolutely crazy
Seth you're from Georgia uh you got to
get in this get it yeah come on this is
not the right
door now okay this is this is an
embarrassment you're putting it on the
national stage for me right now
um yeah it's it's Stacey Abrams is a
mess but fortunately based on what I'm
seeing on the ground there she's not
going to win this race
um she's going to go directly from this
gubernatorial race to she will be
running for president shortly after it
probably I think she actually tries in
2024. I really do think she finds a way
into that because who knows what happens
with Biden I I I wouldn't disagree they
don't have anybody I mean in fact what
was the latest polling like only 24
people 24 of people only 24 people I
believe in now only 24 of people said
they would vote for him at this point
there was a couple polls one said 33 of
people would vote for him so they they
need anybody they can get you got Buddha
judge but he uh talks like this uh and
you're like come on
I'm sorry he doesn't have the Charisma I
know and Stacy just mimics him she's an
election denial you know this is true
she's an election tonight I I can't
support an election denier you know so I
I watched the media talk about election
deniers all day and night and then I saw
this viral video of Stacey Abrams then I
saw another viral video like oh man
she's dangerous for society that's right
it's very dangerous to democracy yes
that she denies election what election
did Stacy deny she denied I think she
may have denied 2016 2018. no no 2016.
the Hillary Clinton and oh man but she
denied her own loss right that's for
governor in Georgia before before she
even got to denying that she lost and
refusing to accept the results of her
own election I think she may have been a
2016 denier as well did you say she lost
her 2018 election then claimed that it
was what rigged she claimed oh yeah she
claimed there was fraud and manipulation
voters oppression well well yeah we had
the highest of black voter suppression
specifically in the election year she
ran we had the highest black turnout in
Georgia history but it was was the same
year that voter suppression kept her
from winning I mean even right now voter
turnout in Georgia is higher than what
it was yeah it's through the roof yes
yeah 73 higher at this point in the
election than 2018. that's incredible
that's nice and they're higher than in
and they're all voting Camp huh well I
don't know about all of them but I do
think that Kemp wins and I think he wins
by a decent margin I think we're in the
seven to ten range what Legend to so
many people voting
in this election more than ever do you
think do you think there was a lot of
efforts to to try to get people to vote
do you think it's mail-in ballots do you
think it's maybe people moving down to
Georgia uh no I I think obviously
there's a lot of efforts all over trying
to get people to turn out and vote but I
think right now you're seeing people
that normally were not paying attention
I'm seeing this personally just from you
know friend groups Etc uh but people
that weren't necessarily paying
attention like what the hell there's a
lot happening here and I don't like it
and I think you're seeing people turn up
and people that were not so political
before they're maybe not speaking out
about it a lot because they're kind of
afraid of backlash but they're getting
out to vote and I think that we're going
to see I think we're if the polls are
tightening as we get closer to the race
and Republican favor
which tends to typically happen I think
we're going to see actually a I think
we're gonna have a pretty big Republican
Victory oh the the real clear politics
national average in the generic ballot
jumped by like two points today so I'm
doing I'm doing a segment and I grabbed
the RCP average and it was 2.8 and I was
like oh look they jumped one point and
then I'm like so I start recording 15
minutes in when I load Real Clear
Politics it it refreshes and now it's at
3.1 and I was like whoa yeah it jumped
even more in the time that I started
talking about it so the national
aggregate poll yeah so so it's it's uh
the generic ballot aggregate so all
these different polls ask people if you
were going to vote in the midterms would
it be a Republican or a Democrat they're
these are not uh the swing District
polls yeah they're asking aoc's District
who are you going to vote for so when
you see the national level a three or
four point swing for Republicans this is
significant yeah I think Georgia at
minimum we will pick up one on
congressional seat in an already Red
State so in one out of you know out of
15 congressional seats that's pretty
significant I gotta imagine that Biden's
almost refusal to talk about inflation
is like gotta be driving people insane
because it's it's obvious with gas
prices going up food prices going up
that there's a big inflation issue right
now and like Biden whenever he's asked
about it what I see he just kind of acts
like it's not not that big it's like oh
it's a global thing it's not but like
duh but also the America is the leading
global economy so it's an American thing
the global economy is an American thing
well now by Design Saudi Arabia wants to
join bricks yeah you know this has been
uh circulating around for a little bit
that's the end of the Petro dollar and
when that happens America is in for a
very very they're going to do a currency
recall probably get rid of the US dollar
do a U.S Central Bank currency and
crypto Go full crypto tax everybody get
people's people's dollars will be worth
a hundredth of what they were worth but
that that's not that's not necessarily
relevant to what's going to happen first
what's gonna happen first is you are not
going to be able to buy anything because
we don't make anything clothing oh it's
going to be brutal it's going to be like
hey I need to buy a shirt here's it's 50
bucks you're gonna go for a white
T-shirt that's right stitch up your old
t-shirts stitch up your old socks as
someone that sells a lot of shirts
there's actually a lot of trouble
getting a hold of just the blank shirts
even print on right now especially
certain sizes like after covid hit and
everything it became a real issue you
know just trying to get all blanks the
United States manufactures very little
we outsourced all these other countries
and we get away with it because the US
dollar is the settlement layer for the
world the Petro dollar the reserve
currency so people are like I need US
dollars to do to do trade deals with
other countries you take a look at what
happened to Gaddafi he wants trade in
Gold he's gone you look at Saddam
Hussein oh started trading with Euro
he's gone but now the U.S can't keep it
up and they try to that's what they do
with the Middle East the war everything
they do is a desperate attempt to
maintain This Global dominance now it's
Saudi Arabia flipping off Joe Biden and
boy are they panicking over this prices
are going up and they can't do anything
about it Saudi Arabia joins brics that's
it US dollars out there Brooks is
already saying you know we can use the
rupee and we can use the ruble we can
use the one we don't need US dollars for
for settlements anymore bye-bye in the
United States this means you're going to
want to buy a computer that computer is
made in Southeast Asia they're going to
say we don't want US Dollars you don't
make anything what do we need your
dollars for we're going to buy from you
not right now it's oil right now they'll
say yeah we need US dollars because we
want to buy oil once we lose this to
Bricks they're going to go you got corn
I guess I guess we could buy coffee we
got food wheat and corn you think that
part of the reason why they're telling
farmers in Europe to stop farming is
because they're trying to set up a
system where now people buy food from
America maybe maybe maybe they had a
meeting where they're like guys we're
going to lose the petrodollar what do we
do uh what do we export the most corn
and corn syrup okay tell our allies to
stop making food
all right I guess if we don't have the
Petro dollar we can withhold food but we
don't have fertilizer either comes from
Russia so true good luck
and I mean I suppose Ukraine as well I I
don't know man it seems intentionally
they're gonna starve people out but it's
gonna be fun the people who have Farms
live in the middle of nowhere who've
been homesteading they're gonna go what
happened and the people who live in
cities are going to turn into like
ravenous ghouls running around eating
each other I don't know what the media
like CNN and MSNBC have been framing
Biden as when they talked about
inflation or if they even talk to them
about inflation on those channels well
for there's the clips I see of them he's
just like kind of a space cadet on that
stuff probably by intention I don't I
think he's intentionally not addressing
it I don't think Biden's intentionally
saying or doing anything it's pretty far
out of it
yeah I mean better calf care next no
wrestling Trinity pressure yeah I don't
think there's a lot of intentions I
haven't heard him mention the Federal
Reserve once the Federal Reserve is the
issue like that there's this private
company printing our money away
Wicked yep
yeah I wonder if uh you guys remember
Zeitgeist yeah the movie you seen that
one yeah so that thing I've actually
seen it it's worth watching people I
missed a lot so this is you know like
the early internet era of conspiracy
theory videos going around and uh you
had like loose change you had Zeitgeist
and in it it talks about false flags and
stuff but I wonder if was it part one
that talks about fractional Reserve
banking probably it was they did like
Jesus and like the the history of
religion that they did Federal Reserve
fractional what was the third one they
had like a three I think it was
conspiracy one nine eleven yeah
so uh they talk about fractional Reserve
I feel like that kind of documentary
going viral or in the early days of the
internet had a huge impact on a lot of
people leads a lot of people to to uh
politicians like Ron Paul and now all of
a sudden you have a culture that
outright understands fractional Reserve
banking enough to reject it understands
the FED enough to reject it
and these people aren't going away you
know like we're gonna have these
conversations all day every day and they
would love it the machine the fed the
establishment the unit party they would
love it if we stopped talking about how
they manipulate the system and steal
money from you not only are they not
going away they took us off fractional
Reserve Banking and now we're on a no
Reserve banking system where they can
print infinite amounts they don't even
need 90 or 9 10 in the bank to loan out
99 cents on the 10. I gotta wonder if
what that means is they know the
system's about to implode and they're
extracting as much as possible in a
currency recall and then everybody's
gonna lose
the U.S look if the U.S loses this the
brics Nations OPEC plus they're going to
be laughing all the way to the bank
because it they can do sure maybe
they'll do a currency recall but it's
pointless the US dollar is going to hit
hyperinflation we don't make anything so
let me just simplify it we go to Korea
and say we want a bunch of laptops and
they say what are you going to give for
us or like what are you going to give us
for it and then we say we will give you
dollars and they go what can I do with
that you can buy from us and what can I
buy from you corn yeah so they're going
to say no thanks the computers are worth
more than the corn you have to offer and
they're going to go to China and say we
need the rare earth minerals and China's
gonna be like deal they're going to go
to Russia and OPEC and they're saying we
need oil and they're going to say deal
and the us is going to be like but we
shut down Keystone Pipeline and we we
stopped energy production so we don't
make energy we don't make uh raw
materials here anymore we don't Harvest
them we do a whole lot of nothing I mean
look we do some of that stuff in the US
but it's way down Trump was trying to
bring back manufacturing and that's
probably why you can see what's
happening but I hope you guys are ready
for a big ride it's gonna be fun yeah
Biden is a horrible Diplomat people
don't like him he's mean
um he he was a terrible military
commander he he we he surrendered our
military Terry to the Taliban in
Afghanistan and people see the weakness
in the idiocy and like the old Frailty
and they just don't take them seriously
I don't that's the vibe I'm getting
Saudi Arabians are like you know if
there's anyone we're ever going to cut
ties with in the United States it's Joe
Biden that guy's a dick it's not
personality it's the policies it's it's
what they're what he's doing that's
pushing forward we I could get in a
whole rant about Saudi Arabia thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there